steering wheel's moving
seat belts fastened
no one's behind the wheel
robo taxis are real
at least here in chandler arizona where
waymo has been offering fully driverless
rides for more than a year leno's
looking left
rainbow's looking right all right
and in august it expanded to san
francisco but rides here still have a
driver behind the wheel
the supporting driver does have hands on
the wheel not always gripping the
steering wheel but always hovering
around the wheel it's an important test
for the company as it could provide a
road map for expansion into other cities
but the race is on general motors cruise
is also testing driverless cabs in san
francisco you could really build a
sizeable ride-hailing business if you
set up operations here but rising costs
and tech limitations have slowed
driverless car companies down so ken
waymo with operations in phoenix and now
in san francisco pick up the pace and
bring its robocaps to more cities and
more passengers
to find out we spoke to company leaders
and yes took a couple rides
we're here at waymo's depot in san
francisco a city that represents an
important test for the company as it
looks to expand its service and well
it's got a lot of cars
waymo's ride hailing service waymo one
is new in san francisco but the company
formerly known as google's self-driving
car project has been testing here for
more than a decade
san francisco provides a wide diversity
of not only geographies but also a
diversity of the kind of interactions
that we'll have on the road itself so
you can see we're in a little bit of a
busier part of the neighborhood here
there are cars parked along the right
there's a truck here stopped unloading
waymo rides in san francisco like the
one the company invited the wall street
journal to take are currently done with
a driver at the wheel but the company
says it's the tech aboard its vehicles
that are making a majority of the
decisions the tech that i can actually
see here what are the main components
the lidar which is the 3760 degree at
the top as well as the smaller ones
around the side the perimeter lidar we
have cameras 29 different cameras
positioned throughout the vehicle and
radar is our third kind and then lastly
within that trunk is where we have the
majority of our compute systems so the
systems that take all those signals
together and combine it run it through
our software to help the car determine
what it should do next all of waymo's
passengers or trusted testers in san
francisco have signed non-disclosure
agreements that prevent them from
sharing their experience well except for
me
so right now waymo is driving us around
a pretty residential area lots of stop
signs
no stop lights on the route so far
i think seeing the supporting driver's
hands hovering and sometimes grabbing
the wheel itself is providing a little
bit of additional security for me
waymo really likes to stick to the speed
limit
last week a waymo car hit a pedestrian
in san francisco the company said the
vehicle was being driven by a human
driver in manual mode when it struck the
pedestrian who was treated for injuries
at the scene and transported to a
hospital by ambulance the company said
the trust and safety of the communities
in which we drive are paramount to us
and we will continue investigating this
incident in partnership with local
authorities
so far seven companies including waymo
and cruz have received permits from the
state to test autonomous vehicles
without a driver but weima wants to be
the first to offer its service to the
public how far off do you think you are
from being able to pull the autonomous
specialists from the vehicle our current
focus is really
continuing to develop a safe and
convenient experience for all of our
riders
so no specific timelines to share at
this time success in san francisco could
help provide a revenue generating
business for waymo analysts estimate its
cars cost two hundred thousand dollars
and it can't yet charge passengers for
rides in the city they don't need to
operate a robo-taxi fleet in a ton of
markets because if you look at the
business performance and results of uber
and lyft they mostly come from just a
handful of cities around the world like
10 cities wsj reporter trip nickel
covers alphabet he lives in san
francisco and like many residents there
has been seeing waymo's cars a lot they
seem to be
on a rotation or a loop in terms of what
routes they drive
to see what waymo could look like in
future markets we went to waymo's first
location a 50 square mile area around
chandler arizona here waymo has pulled
the driver support and riders can now
hail robo-taxis themselves the wheel
is moving by itself
when did you know it was time to pull
the driver out of the waymo here in
chandler we evaluate the performance of
the driver the wemo driver on a given
operation domain we evaluate evaluated
against general features of topography
geography weather and also specific
features such as the unprotected left
turns
and ability to handle a large parking
lot that is the process that we use to
release our technology here in chandler
after traveling more than 65 000 miles
around chandler without a human behind
the wheel waymo opened up its ride
hailing services to passengers like me
willing to try
while there i spent about an hour in the
back of a weimo we're turning
there it goes
i took three separate rides including
one in the dark waymo encountered
construction an emergency vehicle and
took three rights to avoid a left though
i did experience one unprotected left
turn waiting for intersection to clear
and it is starting and stopping a lot
okay
you may be good now waymo
all right we did it
waymo was a defensive driver but the
experience took some getting used to the
biggest hurdle trusting the tech trust
needs to be earned and we earn it by our
excellent track record and we also earn
it through transparency and really
engaging with the public before opening
up its ride-hailing service to the
public weymouth published safety data
from its tests around chandler it
reported 18 collisions over a span of
about 6 million miles driven none of
those collisions were serious in nature
but regardless every single
event is a learning experience do you
have any updated data since launching
the ride hailing service here in
chandler i'll tell you that the positive
trends that we saw in that first report
where we evaluated six million miles has
continued through our service the
company says it completes hundreds of
rides in the chandler area each week and
has served tens of thousands of riders
there it's put them at the forefront of
the driverless car effort but
it's also chandler arizona it's not
you know in 50 states or
much less two states it's really in one
you know one suburb of phoenix waymo's
ambitions however are greater it's now
testing in 25 cities across the u.s
though the company wouldn't say where it
plans to offer rides next
what's slowing waymo down from expanding
to cities across the u.s it's it's
technology really there's been a
realization broadly across the
self-driving industry
that
their ambitions and hopes of creating
something that was like a computer model
that can be scaled and dropped anywhere
in any city
is is not totally realistic it took
waymo three years of on the streets
testing before it offered its ride
hailing service in the chandler area
alone what can we draw from that pace
for weimar's future expansion
i don't know if that's a great proxy we
build on our experience and our
technology such that it takes us less
and less time to learn the intricacies
and be able to drive safely and reliably
in any market because of this waymo
expects to pick up the pace and it might
need to cruz has raised more than 9
billion dollars to support its robo-taxi
efforts waymo has raised nearly 6
billion
but just how many riders will hop in the
back of one of these robo taxis remains
to be seen
[Music]
ride done
[Music]
you